The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listen-only mode.
Hey everyone. It's Mike Botts from Order
Flows and you know, welcome to this
presentation on
trading consistently with order flow.
And you know, it's interesting times
that we're in. You know, everyone's on
basically uh
the entire 90% of the United States is
on lockdown and you know, trading is is
one of those businesses that you can do
from your home. And you know, people are
I know a lot of people are wondering,
you know, what am I going to do now that
you know, I'm at home. How can I make
money? You know, if you know how to
trade actually, you can do it from
anywhere in the world. And I'm going to
show you today how using order flow is
going to help you become a more
consistent trader. And what you're going
to see today is how order flow can help
you understand the market.
And I'm going to show you ways how to
understand the market easily with order
flow, how you can get an edge over other
traders by seeing what they don't. And
I'm going to talk about how to become
consistent in your trading with order
flow. It's going to be very quick, very
to the point hopefully and you know, I
should get through it in about 45
minutes. Now, you know, your end
destination, you know, ask yourself
where you are now, where you want to be
in the future, right? And you know,
generally I like to tell my students,
you know, people that I work with
teaching how to trade, you know, you
don't need 10,000 hours. You know,
there's a lot of people say, well, you
know, you need 10,000 hours of screen
time to become good.
No, you don't, right? Who's got you
know, if you ever break down what this
whole 10,000 hour uh stuff is about, you
know, who has 10,000 that's 5 years,
right? If you work a full-time job,
that's basically 2,000 hours a year.
You're going to spend 5 years of your
life learning how to trade. No, you know
what? If you get the right education, if
you get the right training and the right
tools, you could
um
get from point A to point B much faster.
You know, I tell a lot of people I say,
you know, if in 30 days you don't
understand what's happening in the
market with the order flow or
you don't become more consistent in your
trading, you know, come back to me and
you know, I'll help you break down the
areas that you're struggling on. So,
basically what you have to do is you
have to fix how you view the market. You
know, the whole thing with trading, you
know, is people think that
they can distill what's happening into
the market into a simple equation. You
know, there's a lot of people that come
to trading that have a programming
background, that have an engineering
background and you know, they they they
think, you know, in binary one or zeros
or ones. And you know, trading is a
little bit more
artistic
than that. I don't think artistic is the
right word, but you know, there's
there's so many different little nuances
in the market that you know, trying to
think that everything has got its proper
place in the market doesn't always work.
So, you have to think a little bit
outside the box. You got sometimes you
got to be a little bit
creative in the way you think. Don't
think that everything has to be exact.
There's there's a you know, sometimes 1
+ 1 doesn't necessarily equal two,
right? The 1 + 1 in trading world
sometimes equals 1 and 1/2 and I'm going
to show you what that means later. Now,
the whole focus of this seminar,
okay, what what I want you to get to,
right? This is me in the 1990s, right?
When I was struggling to learn how to
trade, okay? I know I had my old
486 computer, you know, I was manually
typing in data in there versus in 2010
when I was getting an award from the
Singapore Exchange, the SGX for the
amount of volume that we're trading.
You know, I I went from basically
someone that was struggling and didn't
know much about anything to be in, you
know, one of the biggest volume
providers of liquidity on the SGX
Exchange.
And the way I did that is by
understanding how the market trades and
how order flow affects the market. So,
by the end of this webinar,
right? You'll A be able to understand
why
and how something has happened in the
market instead of just what happened in
the market, right? Most traders
they just want to look at a chart and
see, well, you know, price hit this
level and sold off, right? But you know,
if if you're
a real student of the game, so to speak,
real student of the markets, you want to
know why the market sold off from that
level and how it sold off from that
level. And that's what order flow is
helps you to understand the why and how
of what's happening in the market. So,
for those of you that are new to order
flow, new who
to a presentation by me, this is a quick
background
so you understand where I'm coming from,
right? I started on the CME floors a
runner with Dean Witter Reynolds in the
early 90s.
Okay? And eventually, you know, that was
good. I had a lot of fun. I loved the
trading floor environment, but I
realized
things were starting to go electronic,
right? This was, you know, back in the
early 90s, the exchanges CME just opened
up Globex, the overnight session, CBOT
had project A.
The
um NYMEX COMEX had uh
access it was called and the rest of the
world still traded electronically except
for uh the DTB which in Germany
um traded the bonds and bobl and schatz.
That was electronic.
And then, you know,
so I left the trading floor when
everything started going electronic very
early. Honestly, not a lot of people put
a lot of um emphasis on the overnight
session in there, but I realized that
that's probably where the future is
going to be. You know, everything was
going to go electronic and it took a
took about 10 years for things to really
make that shift. But you know, I spent 3
years with Dean Witter on the trading
floor and on their Globex trading desk.
Then I left there to join EDF Man. I
spent 2 years there on the global macro
trading desk. You know, again, we traded
all the electronic markets and all the
voice markets.
Then after that I joined Commerzbank,
the big German bank. I was their
licensed Eurex trader trading bonds,
bobl, schatz, DAX, Euro stocks and then
trading it all against the US products,
right? The the bund is a 10-year
contract. We would trade it against the
CBOT 10-year.
Obviously, the DAX
we would trade against the E-minis at
the time. E-minis were just starting up,
the Nasdaq as well.
After Commerzbank, I joined Cargill. I
spent 4 years there.
I spent
a few years in Chicago and a few years
in Singapore. They sent me out to
Singapore to set up a futures trading
desk when the SIMEX
closed down, closed their trading floor
in 2005.
And after Cargill, I joined JP Morgan. I
spent 8 years there as vice president
futures trading trading on the trading
desk, right? I wasn't sitting in some
corner office, you know, looking at
spreadsheets telling people, oh, you
know, your risk is too high. No, I was
the one banging away on the keyboard um
trading. And then after JP Morgan,
I decided I've had enough, right? Of
this corporate world and
I left. My daughter was born
a few months before I left.
And I started writing a book on trading
and in 2015 I started the company Order
Flows, which is an order flow software
company. Actually, I started it
based on my book, right? I thought I was
just going to write a book on trading,
but then
yeah, I was trading for myself and I was
using another company's footprint chart,
but I realized, you know, I could make
this better, right? Cuz there was ways
that I was using order flow
in the past and you know, at JP Morgan
and currently for my personal trading
that you know, I want to take that
analysis and put it into the software,
into the footprint
so that it can take some of the heavy
lifting on me and I can
concentrate more on managing the trades
rather than spending so much time
looking for a trade, right? Cuz you
know, looking for a trade, finding a
trade is one thing. You still once you
pull the trigger, you get into the
trade, you still got to manage it,
right? And managing a trade takes a lot
of time and I don't say a lot of time,
but it takes a lot of energy. It takes a
lot of
emotional capital
that
having that computer do some of the
analysis for me, it just lets me manage
the the trading more, right? And I could
look at a few more markets. Now,
at the time,
you know, there were there was a few
platforms out there. There was
NinjaTrader, Sierra Charts, um you know,
and a few other platforms. I chose
NinjaTrader because the programmer that
I found
you know, I had already created a
software for NinjaTrader.
So, I said, hey, you know, take these
tools. I'm going to and then put them
into
um
your footprint
and that's what I'm going to use for
trading.
So,
I was just using it for myself, then I
was talking to other people and people
were interested in in using it.
So, that's how the order flows
.com company was born.
Now,
the big advantage for this
of this is that the Order Flows Trader
software users is they don't have to
make the calculations, right? A lot of
calculations, a lot of the analysis that
I was doing
with order flow, I was basically doing
manually, basically doing visually and I
said, you know what? Take all that take
all these different little nuances that
I'm seeing in the markets, put them into
the software, right? So, that's what the
Order Flows Trader software does, right?
It plots all the
all that analysis onto the volume
footprint chart.
Now, what makes the Order Flows Trader
software
um
or any footprint, right? For that
matter,
is
you know, it takes all that information
and traded volume for every market or
time frame and puts it into an easy to
read format, right? You you you don't
want to be scratching your head well,
you know, should I be looking to buy
here or should I be looking to sell
here? You want to say you know, you want
to be able to make the decision like
that. Yeah, I should buy here. I should
sell.
Okay? And
you know, that's where having good
software to help you with your analysis
and do some of the analysis is going to
put you ahead of other traders. Now,
like I said before, you know, in after I
left JP Morgan, I started writing a book
on trading.
You know, it's called trading order flow
and
if you stick around to the end, I'm
going to show you how to get it for
free. I'm going to give you
a download link that you can download it
for free. So,
you know, it's going to behoove you to
stick around to the end. So, what I'm
presenting here is what I've developed
for myself and built my trading career
on. When I say trading career, I don't
mean I I just traded my own account
while you know, I was living
you know, in a one-bedroom apartment.
No,
I traded at JP Morgan, at Commerzbank,
at Cargill. I traded at all these big
firms, right? And you don't last you
know, I spent 8 years at JP Morgan. You
don't last that long at at a at a bank
like that
unless you're good at what you do. And
I'm not saying that to brag or anything,
but
you know, it's
to sit on a trading desk and trade day
in and day out, you got to be producing
numbers, right? You got to be doing
something good. You got to be generating
revenue for the bank, you know, or at at
Cargill, right? You got to be adding
value. If you're just going to be
sitting there collecting a paycheck,
they're going to tell you to get lost,
right? So,
you know, what I'm using, you know, what
I used back then is what I use now in my
trading and it's what I had put into
this form of analysis into the software.
Now, I'm not following saying that you
have to follow what I say just because I
say it. Oh, well, Mike says you have to
buy because of this or sell. No, you
know, you have to evaluate everything
and you know, whether it's from me or
whether it's from someone else, decide
if it's going to help you in your
trading and reject it. You know, trading
is
a very
personal endeavor, right? You have to
have a trading plan that suits your
personality. You know, you you you can't
trade somebody else's method unless it
suits you know, your risk
profile, right? If you know, I have a
certain risk profile, it probably
differs from somebody else. You know, my
wife
has a different risk profile than than
what I have and you know, while someone
may be willing to take a little bit more
risk, you know, someone else might not.
So, you know, you have to find where
you're comfortable and where you are
um you know, with your trading. You
know, you there's there's so many
different ways to trade honestly that um
you know, every risk profile I think
should be covered. But
I'll explain to you how committing to
order flow changed it all for me, right?
Cuz this is about you know, I want you
to understand my personal journey,
right? My
Once I committed to order flow,
everything changed, right? My trading
improved and once my trading improved,
you know, I started getting job offers
at major banks and trading firms that
were very lucrative. Honestly, you know,
when I got to JP Morgan, that was it. I
said, this is it. This is what I'm going
to retire from. Um you know, and I would
get calls like literally every month
from headhunters, you know,
you know,
just because you know, they hear about
you if you're successful, okay? And
it
How did I do it? I do it because I know
how to read the markets, right? When you
understand why and how a market trades,
you can get anything, you know, in life.
I I say when I say get anything, you
know, trading provides a lot of rewards,
okay? If you're good at it, you apply
yourself, it's a very rewarding
um career. And you know, I don't want to
just talk about the money, but you know,
the time that you can spend with your
family because you don't have to
spend 10 hours a day in the office or
going on vacations.
Um you know, so many nice things that
you can do
is the rewards of being a successful
trader, but you have to know how to
trade. So, before I jump into it again,
you know, I talk about my past, but I
want you to understand, you know,
trading involves risk, you know,
when you're trading, use risk capital
that you can afford to lose and only
trade with sufficient risk capital. And
you know, sometimes
people
will say, well,
you know what, Mike? I've got
You know, I've I've got
I've got this lump sum of money
and it's got to last me for 6 months and
I got to get a job. Teach me how to
trade so I don't have to get a job. You
know, don't put yourself in that
position, right? Don't don't be in a
race against time to have to
you know, try and get the get to a level
in trading because you're going to put
yourself under a lot of stress and it's
not going to be healthy. So, again, you
know,
the markets have been there for 100
years. They most likely will be there
for another 100 years.
Take your time.
You know, don't put money that's you
need for other daily living expenses
into a trading account think that you're
going to become, you know, the the next
Tom Baldwin or Paul Tudor Jones. You
know, um
that's not to say that you can't, but
again, you know, be prudent in your
decisions. So, first thing I want to
talk about is, you know, understanding
the why. Why
markets move, you know, and being able
to react to it rather than
that the market just moved. And you
know, the way to describe it is
understanding the market, right? You
want to understand why a market is
moving, not that just it moved, right?
This is this morning in the S&P's,
right? We had our low down here at uh
you know, the 50 I forgot what this was,
51 and a quarter
and then rallied. You know, most traders
will say, well, you know, we hit that
low
and we rallied, you know, they'll draw a
trend line and they'll react to that.
Well, an order flow trader wants to look
at the low and understand why we rallied
off this low cuz it's going to help them
get in to the market at a much better
price.
So,
basic
trading 101, right? For every buyer
there's a seller, right? Well,
then how does the market move, right?
Cuz you know, you have a buyer, you have
a seller,
but for you know, if everyone's happy to
trade with each other at one level,
at one price, the market's not going to
move. It's going to stay at that price
all day long. You have to understand the
different types of buyers and sellers.
And
there are four types of market
participants. I'll just go through them
really quick, all right? You have
aggressive buyers, you have aggressive
sellers, passive buyers, passive
sellers. All right? So, you have
aggressive traders and you have passive
traders. Now, aggressive buyers are
those that buy at the market. They lift
the offer, right? Aggressive buyers
see the bid or sorry, see the offer. You
know, it's it's uh market is six bid at
seven. They buy the sevens.
Next thing it's offered at eight. Okay,
I like eights, I'll buy eights. They're
being aggressive. They're lifting the
offer. They're buying at the market.
Aggressive sellers do the opposite. They
sell at the market. They hit the bid,
right? The market is six bid at seven.
They sell the sixes. They sell the
fives. They sell the fours, right?
They're being aggressive. Passive buyers
are the people that work a bid or work a
bid
um below the best bid, right? Passive
sellers are are those that work limits
on the offer or above the offer. And if
you've ever looked at a dome,
okay? Most of us are familiar with the
trading dome.
Passive sellers are those that are
sitting on the offer on the
you know, above the current offer.
Passive buyers are those sitting on the
bid and below, right? For a trade to
happen, someone has to cross the bid
ask, right? Someone working on either
has to come in and lift the offer rather
than join the bid
or a seller has to come in and sell at
the market
or someone that's working a offer has to
move down and hit a bid, right?
Otherwise, the market's just going to
sit there. It's not going to move. If
everyone's if everyone's just going to
say, I'm only going to pay 50,
you know, to buy and everyone's going to
say, well, I'm only going to sell at 75,
it's not going to move, right? Someone
has to go down, change their mind, hit
the bid. Someone has to think that this
market um is going to go lower, start
hitting the bids. Someone's going to
say, you know what? I don't want to be
long anymore.
Um I just want to get out of my
position, hit the bid. So, you know,
that's what causes markets to move.
However,
you know, there there
there is a limitation
on dome, on depth of market trading is
that
you know, it it moves so fast that
you have to memorize everything,
right? And and it's going to be
difficult as a trader trying to memorize
what's going on
you know, in in the market. You you
can't, right? It's just moving so fast,
you know, you'd have to be like
Rain Man or somebody to understand and
and keep track of what's happening
and you know,
let alone make any sort of educated
trading decision off of it.
Now, the order flow trader footprint
chart, right? Takes all that information
that you see on the dome going back and
forth, what was traded on the bid, what
was traded on the offer and puts it in a
nice easy to read format so that you can
make an educated trading decision,
right? And
an order flow footprint chart shows very
precisely where volume is transacting,
you know, on the bid and on the offer,
the strength of the trading, weakness in
the trading and puts it in an easy to
interpret format so you can analyze that
data in terms of market structure. And
by understanding
trading occurring in the market between
aggressive traders and passive traders,
you can gain an understanding as to what
is happening in the market at any given
point in time. So, you know,
just the facts. The basic facts about
trading. Markets move on aggressive
trading, right? Aggressive trading leads
to market imbalances. Aggressive trading
and market imbalances show up in the
order flow. You just need to know how to
look at it. Now, in the order flow, just
really quick. I'm just going to There's
There's basically three fundamental
parts of the order flow. It's delta, um
imbalances,
and points of control. I'm going to just
run through each of those really quick
so you understand. Now, delta is the
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive sellers in a bar, right?
Remember before I said there's four
types of traders. There's aggressive
buyers, aggressive sellers, passive
traders,
passive buyers, passive sellers.
Delta measures the difference between
the aggressive buyers, people buying at
the offer, versus aggressive sellers,
sellers selling into the bid.
Why is that important? It's because you
want to know who is dominating in the
bar. And even within delta,
there are
four types of
delta that you can look at. Delta,
generally on most software, mine
particular, is on the bottom of the
chart, all right? It keeps it nice and
neat down here. You know, some software
likes to put it above and below the bar,
but at the end of the day, you're just
cluttering up your chart and it's just
you know, you're just going to be
overwhelmed with stuff. You know, I like
I prefer it down on the bottom
because I know where it is. It's easy
for me to to reference. You know, once I
start seeing more numbers,
you know, it just it just adds more
ingredients into the into the recipe.
But you're going to see delta, max
delta, min delta, cumulative delta, and
you know, the volume for the bar.
Now, people say, "Mike, what's the
difference between these different delta
numbers, right? First, you told me
there's just delta, but there's an
you can break down delta a little bit,
right? Delta, again, the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar. Max delta is the
strongest aggressive buyers were in a
bar at one point. So, it tells you how
strong aggressive buyers were in that
bar.
Now, it could be zero. It means that
aggressive buyers were never in control,
right? Or it could be, you know,
whatever number, 100, 200, 1,000. Min
delta is the opposite. It's the
strongest aggressive sellers were
in a bar at one point.
So, you know, it's going to tell you,
you know, again, it could be zero, or it
could be like minus 300, tell you that
at the one point in the bar, the
strongest that aggressive sellers were
over aggressive buyers was 300. Okay?
Now, then there's cumulative delta,
which is the total delta for the trading
session. And again,
it's going to run along the bottom. So,
you know, let's just take a look at what
these numbers mean. So, generally,
markets go down when you have periods of
negative delta, right? Markets go up
generally on positive delta. You can see
as this market is moving up, positive
delta in each bar, right? As the market
was coming down,
you had negative delta in each bar.
Aggressive sellers were in control. Then
it was a positive delta, negative delta
as we went sideways, and then positive
delta again on the move back up.
Simple, right?
Max delta,
again, what does max delta tell you?
It's the
how strong aggressive buying was at any
point in the bar. So, once you start
understanding you know what delta means
in terms of aggressive trading, then you
can start looking at the max and min
delta. Okay? So,
this market, right? This is S&P's
yesterday, right? Remember we rallied
yesterday. And as we're going up
to the high of the day,
you you want to know is this market
going to keep moving higher, right? Or
is it going to hit the high and
potentially sell off?
Well, if you're looking at the max delta
in relation to the final delta, there's
the normal delta, and the min delta,
you're going to see that
yeah, there's there's a lot of
aggressive buying, right? You're seeing
these bars here, right?
There's a bar here, it's got positive
delta of 360. Final had a max delta of
366. So, we're closing right near our
delta, you know, right near our max
delta. 360 is our final delta when the
bar closed. It had a max delta of 366.
That's only six contracts off. Min
delta, zero. At no point were aggressive
sellers in control of this bar.
Next bar,
max delta is 271.
Final delta is 170. Min delta, zero. At
no point were aggressive sellers in
control of this bar. Then it goes back
and forth here, you know, negative
delta, positive delta, negative delta,
and then
positive delta again, 193.
Our max delta was 194. So, we're closing
right practically on our max delta. Min
delta was only minus six. Nothing. Very
little aggressive selling.
Next bar,
max delta is 698.
Final delta, 695. Min delta, minus four.
Again, all aggressive buying, very, very
little aggressive selling. Next bar, 397
max delta.
Final delta, 381. So, again, you know,
we're closing within
um you know, 16 contracts of our max
delta number. Min delta, you know, minus
35, again, kind of small. So, I know
that on this move, it's just being
dominated by very strong aggressive
buying, stronger than normal aggressive
buying. Cuz, you know, normally you're
going to see, you know, mixtures. You're
going to see some positive delta and
usually some decent uh
min deltas in a bar. But when you see
very, very little interest,
then it's telling you, you know, there's
Where's the aggressive sellers? They're
not really there.
Right? Now, looking at it in the
opposite terms, right? The min delta,
if the market is selling off, right? You
want to watch the relationship of the
min delta to the max delta. So,
we're at the high of the day yesterday.
You know, we got a little bit of a
sell-off, right? But if you're watching
what the
um min delta is telling you,
you could see that yeah, you know, we're
up here at the high of the day. I don't
see much aggressive buying. Why? Because
I don't see very strong max delta. And
imagine, you're at your high of the day
and the bars up there have very small
aggressive buying.
Right? I mean, you're at your high of
the day, you got um you know, 102 max
delta, 35 max delta, 200 max delta, 25,
128, 52, zero. Right? On this move up,
these three bars going up into the
highs, you're seeing 591, 825, 1244,
right?
This bar right here on the extreme left,
the delta finished at 589, but you had
max delta of 591. The next bar, 825, we
closed at the delta. Max delta was 825.
This bar at the high, 1244 max delta, we
closed at 1215. Then the next bar,
minus delta, negative delta. That's not
good. Next bar again, negative delta.
You make a new high or you hit the same
high, you got delta of 127. Max delta
was 218. Why aren't you closing, you
know, closer to 218? Instead, you're
sort of closing 100 contracts off. Then
the next bar, you make a new high.
What's the delta? Minus 74.
I mean, at one point it was minus 452.
It gained a little bit back.
But then the next bar,
final delta is 369, -369.
Min delta, minus 394.
So, yeah, it's closing right near your
min delta number. Then the next bar,
final delta is minus 421. Min delta was
minus 421. Where is the aggressive
buying? There's there's, you know,
aggressive buyers are coming in here,
but they're small. 102, 35, 218, 25,
128. They're being engulfed by
the min deltas. We're closing very
strong negative deltas. Do you think
this market's going higher? No. You
know, what's what's there for the market
to go any higher?
It's just not It's just not giving you
any clues that this market wants to go
higher.
Now, the cumulative delta
is Again, it's the delta
at you know, the final delta number,
right? The the top headline number.
And it keeps a track of what it is
during the course of the day. So,
generally, as the market is if it's a
trending day higher,
delta is going to keep getting bigger,
bigger, bigger positive. If it's a
trending day lower,
with a lot of bars having negative
delta,
um you know, it's going to be a negative
number and it's going to be getting
bigger and bigger bigger. But again,
there's clues in here in the cumulative
delta as to what's happening in the
market. Okay? So, for example, okay,
we're going sideways here, and then the
market rallies up, right? It goes from
basically the 26 level up to the 36
level. All the charts I'm using in this
presentation today
are 1-minute E-mini charts.
Okay? Sometimes I like to mix it up.
You know, use a a 5-minute chart or, you
know, an 8-range chart or a 4-range
chart or a volume-based chart, but you
know, then people start worrying because
they think, "Whoa, why am I supposed to
be flipping back between charts?" No.
You know, so today, I'm keeping it
uniform on one chart type,
one duration,
and, you know, one market because, you
know, I I reason I generally will show a
lot of different charts is so you can
see how
the same concepts apply whether it's a
1-minute chart, whether it's a 30-second
chart, whether it's a 5-minute chart, a
15-minute chart, an 8-range chart, a
2,000 volume chart, or whatever you want
to use, or a 987 tick chart, you would
still apply the same analysis there.
But
uh this is cumulative delta, okay?
So, we're trading here around the 2724
area.
And then we go sideways, right?
Now, what's interesting is
we're trading this first bar on the
left,
cumulative delta is 10,063.
Okay, it's positive. But then you just
go sideways here, right? Market's not
going anywhere. You know, it comes off a
little bit, rallies up, comes off.
And over here, about 15 minutes later,
we're still trading the 2726 area.
Cumulative delta is 13,000.
Okay?
So, you went from 10,000
to 13,000 in 15 minutes. So, it gained
3,000 contracts.
The the cumulative delta.
Market's not moving. What's that telling
you?
Is that
every time
the market would stop a little bit,
aggressive buyers would step in.
All right, so people are buying this
market.
They're letting it breathe, sellers come
back in, we're going sideways.
They step back up, buy some more. Let
the market come off a little bit, buy
some more. Let the market come off a
little bit, buy some more.
Okay? And then as you can see here,
right? As we sort of break out of this
2726 area,
after gaining about 3,000 contracts in
the delta,
cumulative delta,
the market popped, right? It went from
up to 36.
So, you know, understanding how to use
the delta is is
is very valuable information. You know,
what people don't realize, you know, all
these little delta numbers, delta max,
delta min, delta cumulative delta,
um you know, is is a data point
basically, right? And you know, you
could use that in your trading to make a
good trading decision. Now, the second
basis of order flow I want to talk about
is point of control. And the point of
control
is the price level in a bar
with the most volume. There's no
mathematical fancy formula to determine
it other than simple arithmetic, right?
You're going to take the volume
traded on the bid, volume traded on the
offer.
You're going to add those up. If it's
the most volume, it's going to put a box
around it, a rectangle around it, okay?
And every bar has a point of control,
right? I I only I put an arrow here just
to show you this one. I I could
put one on each bar, but you know, you
you get the idea, right? And
again, you know, it's there's nothing
fancy, you know, there's nothing sexy
about it other than it's the the point
in the bar that has the most volume. And
why is that important is because, you
know, once you understand volume, you
know, volume over time equals value,
okay? And
you know, if you spend any time with
market profile and volume profile, you
understand the importance of value. And
you know, it's a piece of market
generated information that's going to
help you understand why bars trade back
to a certain level,
right? This is again a 1-minute chart
yesterday in the E-minis. Notice how
this
bar A, right? Trades right back to a
certain level
in the previous bar. Bar B trades back
to a certain level of the previous bar.
Bar C trades back to a certain level
of the previous bar, right? Wouldn't you
like to know
where
a point is in the previous where a point
that the market can trade back to and
then continue on in its original
direction? Well, often times it's the
point of control.
Okay?
You can see here, right? On this bar
12:15, we traded right back to the
previous point of control.
The next bar, we traded within one tick
of that point of control.
The next bar, we traded one tick past
it, okay? And you know, on trending
markets,
this is going to be very important
information. You know, on a 1-minute
chart, you know, honestly, it's not as
what's the term, you know, not I'll say
not as liquid, but you know, when you
start looking at longer-term charts,
5-minute charts, 15-minute charts,
where there's a lot of trade back and
forth, you know, on a 1-minute chart it
could happen so fast.
But you know, on longer-term charts, you
know, you you want to be watching these
points of control.
So, there's some questions here, but I'm
not going to get to those yet. I'm going
to get those to the at the end cuz
otherwise I'll get sidetracked. Um I'm
going to talk a little bit about market
profile and stuff. You know, on market
profile, you're not going to look at
market profile on a 1-minute chart,
right? Or a 5-minute chart. Generally,
people that watch market profile or even
volume profile, they're looking at it
over the course of a trading day, you
know, or or a 4-hour period. And you
know, often times if the market makes a
move,
right? For example,
you know, if imagine these are 30-minute
bars, okay? And I know that I have a
level
um
you know, like if I I'll show you later
on on a market profile chart, but you
know, there's even you know,
you could be looking at a level, oh,
this is an important level, this is my
value area low, okay? Well, we're we're
trading away from it, you know, that's
not going to be much value to you. But
anyway,
we'll
we'll talk about it in in a in a minute
uh when I get to that point. Now, the
third part I want to talk about is
market imbalances, right? Market
imbalances occur when there are more
aggressive buyers than sellers or vice
versa.
More aggressive sellers than buyers
in the two-way auction, right? Remember,
markets move in a two-way auction. Now,
buying imbalance occurs when there are
at least four times as many traders
buying the offer
than selling the bid.
Four to one is sort of like this
industry standard that
most people start off with and and use,
you know, I I still use it.
Doesn't have to be four to one, you
could use three to one, you could use 10
to one.
I know some people that use five to one.
It's 400%. Selling imbalance is when
there is at least four times as many
traders selling the bid than traders
buying the offer. And you know, think of
it this way,
okay?
Is the imbalance on a seesaw, right? You
got you got your big bear versus the
little bear.
Well, who's going to win? The big bear
is causing an imbalance. Tug-of-war,
three against one. You have three little
kids here against one adult. Well, you
might think, well, you know,
even though, you know, all things being
equal, technically the the the three
should win.
Now,
how's it show up on a footprint chart is
buying imbalances
will show up in the volume
as blue numbers. Selling imbalances will
show up as red numbers. Normal order
flow is going to be black.
Now, I know some people use the opposite
terms, you know, you will use a black
ground a black background screen and and
white text. Um you know, but you should
still have blue numbers for buying
imbalances, red numbers for selling
imbalances, and if you're using a black
uh chart with white letters, the normal
order flow numbers, normal trade numbers
would be in white.
Now,
generally as a market
rises, you see buying imbalances.
Aggressive buyers are lifting the best
offer and looking for the next best
offer. Why? Demand is present. So,
generally as a market falls, you see
selling imbalances. You see aggressive
sellers are selling into the best bid
and looking for the next best bid to
sell into. Why is because supply is
present. And if you're looking at a
normal
candlestick chart or bar chart, you're
not going to be able to
tell when there are buying imbalances in
the market. You just not.
You know, I I see sometimes people post
charts places a bar chart and say, well,
yeah, I see you can see the imbalances
here. How? You you can't. You're not
looking at volume. That's the problem
with a normal candlestick chart or a bar
chart is it doesn't look at volume,
right? It's just taking all that
information that volume provides you and
throws it in the garbage.
But if you again, this was this morning
in the S&P's around 9:40. But if you're
looking at
a footprint chart,
what do you see?
Well, you're seeing
a lot of buying imbalances coming in off
the low. Why is because traders like
this low price, they want to be
aggressive. They want to aggressively
get long down here.
Right? You see you can even see on the
move down on these red bars, you're
seeing selling imbalances, selling
imbalances. But now you don't see the
aggressive selling anymore. Instead,
you're seeing green bars, but more
importantly, you're seeing buying
imbalances pretty much in every bar
now that you've hit the low.
So, delta,
point of control and imbalances, you
know, are just basic order flow
analysis, but you can see how useful
they are in making informed trading
decisions, okay? And
that leads into the next part is getting
an edge over other traders is because
you're going to be able to see things
that they're not able to see, right? And
you got to remember who you're competing
against.
Most traders think they're competing
against the market. They're not. They're
competing against other traders, okay?
And what order flow traders see that
regular traders
that look at normal bar and candlestick
charts is they see the volume, right? If
you're looking at a normal candlestick
chart, you're not seeing volume. You
know, people all of a sudden they they
just want to take price and distort it,
you know, and and make it into an
indicator and basically try and fix
everything around price. So, you know,
whether you're using a moving average,
you know, volume profile takes the
volume, okay? You know, this is this is
nice to see, okay? I used to use volume
profile a lot,
but you know, I I realized that
you know, it's it's something that over
the course of the day you should really
be reassessing, right? And because if
you know, if if we're trading up here,
right? And there's some volume up here,
and all of a sudden next thing I know we
sell off to down here, well, well,
what's this information up here
going to do for me? You know, not a
whole lot.
You know, you can look at volume profile
on a smaller time frame. I like to use
it on a smaller time frame. Um you know,
so I could
take a look that, you know, as we're
sort of, you know, trading above the
previous shorter term value area or, you
know, coming outside of the value area,
you know, a potential area for a
pullback. Okay? You know, that makes, I
think, a little bit more sense.
You know,
the
VWAP,
okay, you know, people are just
basically using this as a bastardized
moving average nowadays. You know, fib
traders,
okay, you know, they're just basically
reacting to price, you know, oh, okay, I
got draw my fib lines here. Uh I'll
short it at the 38th. Okay, well, that
stops me out. Okay, I'll get short at
50. I'll get short at 61.8. Uh next
thing you know, it's it's, you know,
gone all against them. Trend lines,
you know, I used to be a big trend line
trader. You know, but the problem with
trend lines is you got to keep drawing
new trend lines.
All right, you you're breaking out and
stuff.
Um you know, some trend lines hold.
But you know, next thing you know,
you're looking at your chart, it's like
you got spaghetti on it. But what are
all these traders doing?
Well, they're trading on based on what
happened. The price hit the line, the
trend line, so I buy. Or price broke the
trend line, so I sell. All right? Order
flow allows you to trade based on why
something's happening in the market or
how something happened in the market.
You know, for example, aggressive buyers
are causing market imbalances, so I buy,
right? Like on the low of the day in the
S&P's today at 9:40, aggressive buyers
stepped in. All you're seeing is
aggressive a lot of aggressive buying
coming in, and the market rallied off
that.
So, you know, you you want to be asking,
you know, did the market move up because
of aggressive buying? Resulted in did it
result in buying imbalances, right? Did
the market sell off because it hit a
level resistant based on a large amount
of volume at a particular level?
You know, has the market been moving
sideways while trade is being absorbed
and distributed?
You know, order flow allows you to see
market-generated information of support
and resistance, buying or selling
weakening, you know, where traders are
trapped, divergence between price and
delta, where value areas, where
market is out of balance, you know, and
much more. So, you know, I'm going to
talk about a few of those, you know,
trapped traders, right? Everyone likes
to talk about trapped traders.
And those are areas where traders are
long and wrong or short in the hole. Not
they spelled hole wrong. Um trapped
traders are traders caught on the wrong
side of the market, and when they get
out of a losing trade, it helps propel
the market in the opposite direction.
Um oftentimes people will talk about
trapped traders as if there's thousands
and thousands of traders that are
trapped. Often it's not, you know, often
it's just a a handful of traders, but
that
initial, you know, their their initial
reversal is sometimes enough to cause
a move. Okay? So, you can see here at
the high of the day. Now, I was telling
you earlier, the Order Flows Trader
software
allows
me to do the analysis um without having
to do it myself. I'll let the computer
do it. And one of the tools that we have
on there is we draw these green arrows
for trapped traders at the,
you know, on up candles, trapped traders
on down candles will have a red uh down
arrow. So, I can see here at the high of
the day, this is yesterday, when we hit
2836, there was trapped traders up here.
Market sold off on the move up, you
know, as we came back into these this
buying imbalance, the stacked buying
imbalance, there were some trapped
traders here. You know, we traded right
back to that point of control.
Okay, the market sprang up, and then we
hit this area up here of of some trapped
traders, and then the market sold off.
Um you know, another example,
this was, again, yesterday, right? We
sold off, we came down to this 27, you
know, 98 and 1/2 level. Trapped traders
down here, right? This is the software
telling me, "Hey, Mike,
you got trapped traders down here." All
right? I mean, I could tell you why this
is,
but
you sitting at the computer trying to
look for it, oftentimes you're going to
get blinded by all the other information
that you're looking at and some of this
other analysis that you're trying to do.
You know, I just let the software alert
it to me, you know, hit me upside the
head, said, "Hey, Mike, you know,
there's there's potential trapped
traders right here." All right?
And if you're looking at a normal
candlestick chart,
you're not going to see trapped traders
here. You know, people will say, "Well,
there was a stop run over here, and then
the market reacted and it rallied up."
But you know, at that high here at the
one of the 9:20 time, all right? Who's
going to see that there was trapped
traders up here, even though there was?
All right, market sold off, there was
trapped traders down here.
All right, just I mean, go back to the
previous chart. This blue arrow is that
area on the previous chart that I just
showed you, right down here.
All right? If again, if you're just
looking at a normal candlestick chart,
you're not going to be able to tell
that. You're not going to be able to see
that. You're not going to be able to say
with authority that there's trapped
traders there. Let the software do it.
Now, the other thing I'll talk about is
market sweeps. Okay?
What is a market sweep? Well, sweeping
action is when somebody when a large
trader
has to execute an order which will move
the market, and wants to get on as much
as possible as quickly as possible by
buying through several levels of the
offer or selling through several levels
of the bid. Okay? And we used to use
this term, "Sweep the leg, Johnny." You
know, the old Karate Kid movie. Um
because, you know, when we're working,
you know, before when I was
working on the institutional side, you
know, we would
have a position that we want to get on,
and we just look at the order book.
Okay? Let me see how much I could buy.
Um you know, and we just buy it up how
many levels. You know, if I could fill
the whole order,
okay, fine, you know, cuz I wanted to
get in,
you know, as as quickly as possible.
Actually, the old NYMEX access system,
the electronic system back in the '90s
from NYMEX had that function, you could
do it. Um
you know, it was kind of neat, and
that's how
um you know, that's why a lot of uh
crude oil traders uh sweep the market.
That's why sometimes in in crude you see
a lot of sweeps.
But if you're looking on a normal bar
chart, you're not going to be able to
see where
orders, you know, where traders swept
through the market.
But on a on a footprint chart, you can
get a
clue by looking at the volumes that are
being traded, and it's often against
imbalances, right? So, you can see here
on this blue arrow,
you see very little counter trade. You
see 1 2 3 4 5 6, you know, seven buying
imbalances here. But look at the counter
trade, you know, it's zero against
eight, three against 28, zero against
31, zero against 25, nine against 70,
three against 29, 61 against 275.
Okay? Someone just came in and basically
bought it from 01 up to 03. Turned it
bid. There's 209 now on the bid here.
All right? Market went up.
Next bar opened up, traded right back to
that level where that heavy volume was.
All right, and then continued back up.
Somebody swept through that market here.
All right? Down here,
you know,
I would call this a sweep just because
there's there's a few strong of zeros
here. You got zero against 40, zero
against 68, 21 against 148, then it
turns offer here with some decent size.
So, somebody just sold it down one point
here, somebody bought it up two points.
People say, "Well, why why would
somebody want to buy through
um
the market?" Well,
they think the market's going to move,
right? And they think that if they don't
do it,
somebody else has the same idea of the
as them, they're going to buy those
offers or they're going to hit those
bids.
They don't want that, right? Traders are
greedy in general, you know, they they
want to get in
out of a position
as quickly as possible with as much
money as possible. You know, here, it's
another nice example, no counter trade.
Two against 19, two against 42, then
zero against 50, zero against 64, zero
against 69, zero against 109, zero
against 125, zero against 124. This was
just someone coming with a big order,
maybe buy about 500, turned it bid here,
maybe they're buying a thousand, turned
it bid here to get the rest on.
Okay? Why is because we're coming up off
a swing low. Traders,
you all like buying off lows.
And you see no counter trade. If there
was counter trade, you know, instead of
just, you know, two against 42, instead
of just lift this offer in a split
second, just like that. Buy me a
thousand up to 60. Their average price
probably going to come out around 27.59.
And probably 59.34,
something like that.
Which just looks good when the market's
trading 27.61.
You got to think about that. All right?
And sweeps happen
um fairly regularly. Now,
taking it a step further on points of
control, right? Remember what I said
before as point of control acting as key
support or resistance.
Now,
what I've done in the software is I want
to highlight
what I call prominent point of controls,
point of controls that mean something.
Okay? And again,
if you're looking at
a normal bar chart, you're not going to
see the point of controls. So, I'll just
stick to an order flow footprint chart.
And now again, every bar has a point of
control, as you can see, right? That's
the big rectangle here
appearing, but there's going to be times
when
a point of control is very important and
it's going to act as support or
resistance in the near term.
Okay?
This is it right here.
Where the circle is and the software,
the order flow trader software will
highlight it, right? It colors it uh
it's a cyan color.
And you can see how the next bar opens
up, trades right
gets to that point of control, gets one
tick through it, trades just four
contracts and you know, the market had a
nice rally off that. Off this, you know,
not off this point of control, but the
point of control is telling me that
there's
in this case support here, right? If it
was on the upside, it would be a bearish
point of control, which would be um
colored
sort of a magenta color.
Okay? And again, if you're just looking
at the normal footprint chart trying to
decide, well, which points of control
does matter here? Does anything matter
at all? Well,
let the software do it for you. It's
right here in the middle
at 11:50. These two points of controls
are prominent point of controls.
You can see it's coming in right off
this this lower, you know, this low of
this range here.
And you get a nice move from 26 up into
the 30s, then you you go sideways here.
Then you start coming back down to that
area, but this was the move to be had
here, right? Imagine you're getting long
around, you know, the 26 and 1/2, 27
area. You go all the way up to 30. Okay?
Then just go sideways, you know, you
should be able to recognize when the
market is going sideways when you start
putting together
um
you know, bars that the same heights,
that's a sign of um a market going
sideways. Now,
again, prominent point of control,
right? Market
went up,
hit a level, sort of went sideways,
started coming off, hit a level, went
sideways again.
Right? Well, wouldn't you like to know,
you know, areas that you can buy or sell
based on support or resistance generated
by the market? Well, these are those
areas right there.
Right? And if you're
not using a software that's going to
highlight it to you, you're just going
to be guessing, right? Let the software
highlight it to you. Right? You can see
here, right? It's magenta color.
Okay? Comes off
to where? Here, where you got
a
a cyan color. You got support now. Okay?
You can see how the market went up, came
back to those levels, went back up, came
back to that level, went back up, came
back to that level.
So,
who's that?
You know, the aspects of order flow
analysis such as point of control,
delta, imbalances, and other information
is very useful tool for assessing the
market, right?
You want to be able to identify and
evaluate trading opportunities. And
perhaps the most important is adding
order flow to your trading arsenal is
going to help you in finding trades that
the public misses, right? That's the
power of order flow is seeing things
that other people aren't seeing in the
market, but is a you know, it's not like
hocus pocus stuff. The exchange puts out
data.
Use that data, right? Why why do you
want to
not use that
that that information? There's a reason
why the market the exchange puts it out
and you know, these big trading firms
pay a lot of money for data, right? They
they pay a lot of money to data mine,
you know, all these data points, delta,
point of control, max delta, min delta.
These are all
data points that are being used by HFTs,
by, you know, obviously tape readers, by
order flow traders.
And you know, honestly, if you're not
using that information,
you're not going to
I don't want to say you're not going to
be successful trading because you can
there's different ways to trade, but you
know, it's like being in a car, right?
My my wife's a good driver, but she just
knows how to look at the speedometer,
how fast she's going. She's not caring
about how much oil's in the car, how
much air's in the tire, um
you know, how much um
you know, tire pressure is or anything
like that. I'm interested in it because
I know that if tire pressure is low,
it's going to affect the performance of
the car. If oil is low, the car's going
to eventually stop working.
Um
you know, so
yeah, it's it's information that you can
use in your trading. Now, the last part
I want to talk about is becoming
consistent in your trading with order
flow. And
you know, people always ask, Mike,
what's the holy grail
with uh
you know, in trading? There is no holy
grail, but really
the holy grail is becoming a consistent
trader. That's like the holy grail.
Well, people think what's the holy grail
is like some
thing you, you know, a cup you drink out
of or something. It's it's not. It's
more of a it's more of a concept. It's
it's consistency. You know, it'd be like
Michael Jordan found the holy grail for
basketball is being consistent
basketball player, you know, whether
he's playing in practice or playing in
game six of the finals, he puts the same
intensity and focus
all the time. Right? And being a
consistent trader is, you know, being
consistent in your market analysis,
being consistent in your order entry,
being consistent in your focus, being
consistent in your action. Right? That's
why it
Yeah, I'm from Chicago. So, obviously
I'm a big Bulls fan, okay? And
there's always this talk,
Michael Jordan or LeBron James, who's
the goat? And you know, the greatest of
all time.
And for me there's no comparison
because Michael Jordan would put it out
there
all the time, every game. You know,
LeBron James is, okay, now I'm turning
on playoff mode, you know, like we're
making a playoff run in in the season.
No, you should be playing at that same
level
all year round, not just taking it easy,
waiting for the playoffs to come around.
You know, it's such a waste of talent in
that case where, you know, this guy he's
LeBron James is so great, so good.
Imagine what he could
the the level that he can be at
if he's
applying that day in and day out. So,
you know, it's hard to be consistent as
a trader when you focus on the outcome
more than the process. Put it another
way, right? We're more drawn to positive
feelings of outcomes rather than the
struggle of the journey.
Most of us quit during the struggle
before we can experience the rewards of
staying the course. And in trading, what
that means is,
you know, people they they want to go
out and buy
a system, right? Everyone, you know, buy
an indicator. And after a couple of
losing trades, that's it. It doesn't
work. You know, and give me my money
back.
Um you know, your
whatever reason. You know, but
it's cuz they don't stay the course,
right? They they don't you know,
they get sidetracked by one or two
losing trades and then, you know, they
don't understand it. Their whole trading
plan gets thrown out the window. You
know, they should be trading one lot, so
next thing they know, they're they're
trying to trade three lots to get the
money back. You know, that's not being
consistent, right? Being consistent is
is is like a process, okay? And often
times, you know, as traders we we get so
caught up in
I hate to say the money of it, but you
know,
that's why honestly, that's why a lot of
people come to trading is is because of
the money because it it's can be very
good if you're good at trading.
But you know, they're looking at the
outcome rather than the process and and
for me that was the big difference is
the process, you know, understanding how
the markets worked, what made the
markets go up, what made the markets go
down.
Right? The outcome,
once I understood how the markets
worked, you know, the outcome was the
rewards, right? It would come to me
naturally
as long as there was,
you know, decent uh
you know, commitment to the process.
Now, order flow analysis allows you to
become consistent because it's based on
the same concepts we use in our daily
lives, right? You buy on strength. You
sell on weaknesses. You just have to
apply it to the market. And if you're
looking at a normal bar chart, right?
And drawing your trend lines,
where's the strength and where's the
weakness? You don't know, right? You
don't know if this trend line is going
to hold or break because you don't know
how strong that move is or how weak the
move is, right? If it's a
testing a trend line to the upside,
okay,
when we get to that trend line, is the
market strong or market weak? You know,
that's how adding order flow is going to
help you in your trading, right? It's
going to help you with your entries.
It's going to help you with your exits.
It's going to help you with your money
management. You know, lack of
consistency brings a lack of interest,
right? If, you know, people like to
the butterfly effect is what I call it.
You know, they like to jump from
indicator to indicator
and hopefully something sticks, you
know, it's like a butterfly goes from
flower to flower, right? It goes from
pretty flower to pretty flower.
Be consistent with something, you know?
Learn the process. Learn what it takes
to make something work. You know, that's
why
um
you know, the the best
I don't want to say the best, but you
know, good cooks, okay?
Are are people that enjoy cooking,
right? They want to try new things. You
know, it's not like, well, you buy a
cookbook, you try one recipe and you
don't like the way you cooked it, so ah,
Julia Child, she doesn't know anything
about cooking, you know, she's she's a
scam artist putting out these cookbooks.
Her recipes suck. Well,
maybe it's not Julia Child's, it's it's
you the one that that's not following
the directions, not cooking it properly.
So, you know, you're not consistent in
following
the process, right?
Consist Constantly re-drawing levels,
right? If you're using, you know, pivot
points or trend lines or whatever, you
know, adjusting them,
it's not going to be consistent, right?
Comes down to understanding why the
market is trading in a certain way as
opposed to what the market just did,
right? And you know, practice practice
practice, everyone thinks you know,
there's a saying I remember growing up,
you know,
how do you get to Carnegie Hall? Right,
Carnegie Hall is the big concert hall in
New York City.
And they say practice practice practice,
meaning you got
you know, keep practicing your violin.
Well, it's not just practice, okay? You
have to have learning. You have to have
training. You have to have instruction.
You put that together with your
practice, that's how you reach success,
all right? And by understanding what's
happening in the markets, you can
understand why a market is rallying,
okay? So, it's like here, right? Market
yesterday rallying up to new highs.
Anytime you get to a new high, you want
to be asking, can this market go higher
or is this market going to start selling
off?
Well, I know it just by looking at the
delta.
This is what I call the delta surge. You
got these three bars here as you're
making the new highs.
184, 587, 1411. Delta is growing, it's
getting stronger, okay?
I know now aggressive buyers are in
control. Obviously, you got the positive
deltas, but they're getting stronger
coming into the market. I see buying
imbalances. Yeah, I think this market's
going to go higher.
Okay?
You know, putting it together, right?
High of the day, all right? Anytime you
hit a high of the day, you want to be
asking yourself, are we going higher
or is this it? Is this going to be our
high of the day for the day? Or are we
going to make a new high?
So,
we're at our high, what do I see?
It's it's And it's again, it's not about
being
so smart, you know, about being a rocket
scientist. You know, nowadays to get a
job in a trading firm, you literally
have to have a math degree or
you know, a physics degree or something.
For what? All you got to do is you
simple, our aggressive buyers are in
control. Yeah, on the way up they are.
You hit your high, okay, I know I got
some trapped traders up there at this
red arrow, but just looking at these
bars, let's say aggressive sellers, more
aggressive sellers, more aggressive
sellers. Well, if aggressive sellers are
in control and you see the negative
deltas,
do you think the market's going higher
or not? No, the market's not going to go
higher.
Right? It's it's
more inclined to come off if aggressive
sellers are interested in selling at the
highs.
Now,
you know, a lot of times markets bump
around up or down, a little rally here
five points, 10 points, come off, go
back up. You know, here was you know, a
market
This was yesterday, market was coming
off a little bit. You hit these, you
know, four or five bars where you got
positive delta, okay? On this move down,
yeah, mostly negative deltas, you know?
You didn't get some small deltas two,
nothing, 41, small, you know, 267, okay?
But everything else is mostly negative,
five, 400, 500 negative, 300 negative,
500 negative, 1,000, 400. Then you hit
this three-bar area, positive delta,
369, 726, 685. Market is starting to
tick a little bit up.
Is this
is this going to be a new swing low?
No, possibly.
But, you know, as you're watching what's
happening in the market, you get up to
this little high here,
what's the delta? It's 12. At one point
it was positive 292.
This market's not going to rally up on
small delta
or negative delta.
It finishes at 12. It was positive 292,
so it was plus 292
just to minus uh ended up at 12. So,
it got all the way up there, and then it
came all the way back down in terms of
delta. All right, got up to 292, gave it
all back, basically 280 contracts.
Closed at 12. Then the next bar,
big strong negative delta, 774.
Min delta was 829, so we're closing, you
know, pretty close to our min delta
number.
And you're seeing 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
selling imbalances in that bar. You
basically took out that whole move up.
Obviously, the point of control, we're
below the previous point of control.
Which is also bearish.
And what happens? Well, you know, market
sells off from 12 down to 02 over the
next 8 minutes.
Right? That's how order flow is going to
help you see things in the market that
that other people aren't seeing.
So,
let me ask you a question, right?
If you see net aggressive buying, i.e.,
cumulative delta positive at the lows of
the day, then the market bounces and
retests the lows, and cumulative delta
is not only still positive, but
stronger,
do you think the low is going to hold?
Oh, what do you think? You mean,
obviously it's it's
you're at your low,
you're pushing down into lows,
cumulative delta should be negative,
right? It should be getting stronger
negative, not stronger positive, okay?
So, this was this morning.
In the S&P's, right? We hit this low
here at 9:40 at 51 and a quarter, right?
Cumulative delta is 3,964.
Okay, we rally up a little bit.
Okay, then we come back down, we get
within um
about a point and a half
here at the 52 and 3/4. Cumulative delta
is now 7,000.
Okay, so it went from 3,900 to 7,000.
Okay, then you take a look again.
Yeah, here, come to the swing low, it's
6,400. So, you know, it's a little bit
less, it's like 600 less than it was
just a few minutes ago.
Now you start putting a little bit
higher low.
It's 7,400. You know, when I say a
little higher low, you're talking less
than a point, probably about three ticks
between this low and this low, but it's
7,000 now.
All right? Then as you can see, the
market starts moving back up. Okay, but
you got to listen to what the market is
telling you, right? This is it on a on a
chart on a bar chart, it's a little
easier to see.
3,900 at the low of the day.
Still hanging around your low of the
day. Now, cumulative delta is 7,000.
Still hanging around the low of the day,
7,400
before you got this move from
you know, 60 up into the 70s.
Right? So,
as you can see,
aggressive buying, right? Cumulative
delta is getting stronger. You're at
your lows of the day. Do you think
we're going to go lower if every time
you sort of come back to the lows of the
day, aggressive buyers appear and start
buying it? No. Right? It's it's again,
it's like I said, it's not
there there's some science behind it,
but it's not rocket scientist.
Rocket science.
Um you know, again, you know,
consistency is what transforms average
in
to excellence.
You know, people think that um
trading systems and methods are magical,
right? And
I could say from my own experience is,
you know, for people that have bought my
software,
is, you know, sometimes, you know, every
it's just like, you know, they want
something that's just going to spit out
trades, buy here or sell there, buy here
or sell there. No, you know, there's
going to be times, you know, order
markets exist for
a purpose, right? They they exist to
transfer risk, but there's times that
what's happening in the market is so
obvious, so clear
that you you can't help yourself but
taking those trades. You know, everyone
thinks that order flow is going to be
like this magical thing that's going to
give them every single turning point in
the market. No, it it's not.
You know, it's a tool, right? Just as,
you know, carpenters have a set of
tools, order flow is a tool, okay? And
you know, people will say, well, you
know, if order flow is so great, why
don't you just keep it to yourself and
and make a lot of money? I did. I made a
lot of money, you know, trading.
You know, I had a very good career. I
was able to retire at 43. I didn't want
to eventually get into a software
business, that wasn't my goal. I sort of
fell backwards into it
um you know, after writing my book and
creating my software for myself.
But, you know, reaching the top,
reaching, you know, a high level doesn't
mean somebody else gets pushed down.
There's a lot of room for everybody up
at the top, right? It's not like, oh,
you get up to, you know, a very
successful level in trading that you
knock somebody else off the pedestal.
No, you don't. It's it's a level.
Everybody's welcome, right?
Now, order flow analysis provides
you, the trader, the kind of advanced
information that you need to gain an
edge over other traders, the
competition, right? And then and people
say, well,
you know, when when I I talk about
competition, you know, knowing who
you're trading against the market or
individual traders, you know, it's the
cumulative of the other traders, I
guess.
Um
but
it's a bit bit esoteric in that sense,
you know, when I say
you you're not competing against the
market, you're competing against other
traders, you're
competing against other traders'
thoughts in the market, you know, what
they view the market. Right? I see a lot
of people, everyone's got a view on the
market. Everyone thinks that this
market's going up or it's going down.
You ask anybody, a taxi driver,
um you know, a hairdresser now, um
everyone's going to have a view on on
where they view the market. And you
know,
that's understanding sort of the
mentality that you're competing against.
So, but hopefully by now, you can see
how powerful order flow is and the
analysis
in determining, you know, things like
price. So, I didn't talk about price
rejection,
um but seeing support and resistance,
you know, price rejection, you know,
order flow is great for seeing prices
being rejected. And and that's very
good, especially if you're using, you
know, if you have your own levels,
right? If you if you have a way, you
know, your own pivot points or your own
way of trading, you know, watching how
the market comes to those levels and
reacting at those levels
is going to give you insight
into taking a better trade. You know,
most traders don't you know, good
traders they don't always just take you
know, there's a signal I got to take it.
No, they like to see how the market
reacts around it and by using order flow
you can see how the markets react around
levels. So, you know, hopefully by now
you'll want to add order flow
to your trading, all right? And there's
different ways you can go about this.
You know, number one, you can do it on
your own. You can spend a year, two
years, three years, five years looking
at a screen trying to figure it out
yourself. You know, spend 10,000 hours.
Honestly, I I there's probably people
out there spent 10,000 hours looking at
a dome, looking at a footprint chart,
still don't understand it. You know, you
can waste a year losing more money
trading, right? Or two, you get an
education software from a trader who
successfully traded order flow at the
highest level
for decades. You know, you guys skip the
massive trading losses, skip the wasted
time. You know, time is There's a
saying, time is money.
And it's really true, right? You don't
waste your time
trying to figure stuff on your own when
you could fast track it. You know, it's
like going to Disney World, right? You
can fast track certain rides. You know,
when you get your ticket you say, okay,
I want to do this, you know, I want to
do this a small world um fast track so I
can skip the line.
And you know, I want to do
Toy Story thing. I want to skip the
line. You know, the other ones yeah,
fine. I'll I'll I'll wait in line. And
trading is the same way. Why should you
sit there well, you know, now I'm going
to spend years trying to figure this
out. I'm going to stand in line trying
to figure it out when you can just sort
of jump the queue.
Now, the Orderflows Trader is a software
that I created.
And
when I say I created, you know, my my
programmer created it based on
my input, right? What I wanted to see.
So, all the the tools you see in there
are my own ideas that I've used in my
own trading. You know, a lot of people
have
seen my software, taken those ideas,
tried to reverse engineer them, put them
out in their own software as algo this,
algo that, you know, order flow algo
this, algo order flow algo that when it
it's it's not any fancy algo. You know,
they they like to throw on these
buzzwords. Um
you know, like algo so people oh, it's
an algo I better spend thousand two
thousand dollars buying the software cuz
it says algo in it. It's not, you know,
I just showed you how to simply look at
delta, point of control imbalances to
make good trading decisions. Now, the
Orderflows Trader software is for Ninja
Trader 8 and it's going to work on the
paid version. It'll work on the free
version. So, if you're trading, you
know, if you live in Malaysia and you
trade um through a local broker there,
you can get the Orderflows Trader, put
it on the free version
of Ninja Trader.
Just get a data feed and you can use it
as your charting software. Just enter
your order through, you know, your
broker's front end.
And it comes
programmed pre-programmed with seven of
my order flow indicators. I talked about
the trap traders today. I talked about
the prominent point of controls.
Um there's other ones like market sweep.
Um
ratios, divergence and and a few others.
Normally, I sell this for $8.99 on my
website, right? But having order flow
software is one thing. You have to know
how to use it, right? I don't want to
just give you software and send you on
your way. Okay, go spend the next year
learning how to read order flow. That's
why I provide a lot of education, okay?
If you get my software, I give you
access to my order flow trading course.
It's a 20 video lessons, 15 hours of
video instruction on there, right? I
originally created this thinking they
all would be something people can binge
watch on a weekend in 6 hours and after
I finished recording it turned out to be
15 hours.
But then
people wanted asked me I I want to know
more about order flow. So, I created
this inner circle a few years ago and
there's 56 videos on in it on advanced
order flow tricks, tips and analysis.
Right? And I'll give you access to those
56 videos. Normally, if you want access
to that, it's going to cost you about
$500, $4.97 just to get those 56 videos.
I'm going to give it to you also for
free, right? So,
normally, the software is $8.99, the
training the order flow trading course
$2.97, the inner circle video series
$4.97. That's $16.33, okay? But
I realize, you know, now where
everyone's on sort of house arrest on
this lockdown, you know, people got a
lot of time to spend and so I'm going to
give an extra course. It's what what I
consider my my favorite course that I
created on order flow trading, the order
flow playbook, right? You can buy it off
my website. It's normally it's $2.97.
I'm also going to include that for free,
right? So, all that together, $8.99,
$2.97, $4.97, $2.97, it's $1,900, almost
2,000.
But maybe you're skeptical. Mike, I
don't know about your order flow
software.
You know, this what other people are
saying. Mike, your Orderflows Trader
software is remarkably helpful. I can
see clearly now
what's happening in the market. For
example, who's in control on the market
on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well.
You know, other comments, comments on my
YouTube channel, right? Personally, I'm
very thankful for all the learning and
yes, my trading understanding of
financial markets are way better than a
lot of traders out there.
Okay? I'm writing this because I saw the
difference and when you are in it and
learn trading with order flow you'll
notice that this is true trading based
on economic laws and common sense.
Thanks a million, Mike.
You know, I I took your course a month
ago, right? You really give a fresh and
sane air in the field. Very impressive.
You know, so you know, it it's out
there. You know, but you know, success
you have to go get it, right? It's just
not going to fall into your lap, right?
You have to be aggressive. So, you know,
if you want to get my software, what you
got to do is you you go to
orderflows.com
/oft2.
Okay? See the the link is there in the
in the um
chat box, right? It's just $6.75. It's a
one-time payment, right? And normally, I
don't sell it this cheap. Honestly, I
sell it for more, but you know, we're on
this lockdown thing and you know, a lot
of people are struggling to
you know, some people don't know if
they're going to have a job in a month
or two. You know, some people already
lost their jobs. So, you know, I want to
lower the barrier of entry so you can
take advantage of this downtime
to learn more about trading, learn more
about the market. So, what you got to do
is you go to that page off
orderflows.com/oft2.
This is what it looks like. You just
scroll down the page.
Right? You can watch the videos in
there. I give very clear explanation of
what you're getting, right? You're
getting the Orderflows Trader software
plus the education courses
for $6.75. Then you click on that
button, you know, I want this, right? It
takes you to PayPal. PayPal processes
the payment. I don't get your credit
card. I don't want it. Um PayPal handles
all that. So, you just go
to um orderflows.com/oft2.html.
Now,
what no one's going to tell you about
becoming a successful trader is
it takes work on your part, right?
People who buy order flow trading
software and fail do so because they
think they're buying an easy pie in the
sky get rich quick magical formula,
right?
People that fail don't want to
understand what's happening in the
market. They just want tell me where to
buy, tell me where to sell. Honestly, if
that's your mentality, if you don't want
to understand what's happening in the
market,
my software is not for you, right? My
software is for those that want to
understand how to read the market.
Okay? So,
you know, sometimes people think they're
buying a software that's going to feed
them, soothe them, change their diapers.
No, it's not. It what's going to do is
going to take the information. It's a
tool, right? And put it into an easy to
read format so you can make an informed
trading decision. And again, it runs on
Ninja Trader 8, right? And you can see,
okay,
what's happening in the market, right?
Here was a market that was selling off,
right? You got aggressive sellers coming
in here, selling imbalances, selling
imbalances, all negative delta. You hit
your bottom here, aggressive buyers come
in, stack buying imbalance, positive
delta. Then it just sort of goes
sideways a little bit and then the
aggressive buying reappears here,
positive delta getting stronger as the
market is rallying back up, right? If if
you don't want to do that,
you know, take
I don't say do the work, but you know,
just have that information there so you
can make your trading decision, you
know, then again, you know, Orderflows
is not for you. Orderflows is for people
that want to be traders,
right? You know, people want to
be a trader, but don't want to put in
the the the time and effort. You know,
honestly, like I said, you know, I've
worked at very big trading firms, JP
Morgan.
Nobody uses an indicator there, right?
They learn how to read the market. You
know, when I worked at Cargill, you
know, someone made a comment earlier in
the chat about the salt.
You know, Cargill salt
division is actually a a big division
and that's actually how Cargill got
started was in the salt business. You
know, they were transporting salt up the
Mississippi River. They would transport
um like meat down the Mississippi or
corn down the Mississippi and salt back
up, you know, but you know, people that
learn how to trade at Cargill, they have
a very good trading training
m- what do you want to call it? Trader
training program
is they teach you how to understand
what's happening in the market,
right? And and order flow
teaches you what's happening in the
market, right?
You can see here how the market you had
a bearish prominent point of control,
market sold off. Then the market started
rallying. You got multiple buying
imbalances in these bars,
three here, three here, strong buying
positive delta, right? The market goes
sideways, a bullish prominent point of
control, it's more positive delta as the
market goes back up, right? Being able
to just see that information, see that
what's happening in the market
at a glance
is going to give you an edge over
somebody else, right? It's going to
People aren't going to notice that hey,
you know, I've got a market generated
level here, Bearish prominent point of
control tell me there's resistance here.
And it sells off to where? An area where
you have a prom- a bullish prominent
point of control telling you there's
support down here and the market rallies
right back up.
To where? Your previous resistance
level.
Right? So again, you know, like I said,
it's
understanding the market is going to
make your life a lot easier.
So, you know, if you stuck around, thank
you. It's uh been going on about an hour
and 20 minutes. You can get my book.
Go to orderflows.com/book.html.
You got to enter your name
and email
and hit submit. It takes you to the next
page, which is the download page. It'll
actually load it into your browser.
Um
and then you can just download it, you
know, to your computer or your
smartphone or whatever you're using,
your tablet. Um and it's good read, you
know, it's it's a very good read. So,
you know, why you want to get involved
in order flow analysis is cuz it cuz
it's going to transform your trading.
You know, I've seen it. I've seen with
people that
brand new to order flow, I've seen how
it changed their trading and it's
improved their trading. Right? You want
to understand why and how the market is
trading, what's causing the market to
move.
Right? More importantly, you want to
become a consistent trader.
Right? You don't want to just be taking
stabs in the dark, well, I think this
trend line is going to
hold or not. You know, I mean, that's
not being consistent.
But more importantly, right? You want a
life of freedom and fulfillment, right?
I'm not going to sit here and and tell
you, oh,
you know, you you're going to be a
millionaire in a week. No, you know, you
got to do work on your part, but if you
put in the work
and you take the time to learn the
markets, yeah,
you can be greatly rewarded. So,
go to orderflows.com/oft2
and it'll take you to, you know, how to
get started. So, I'm going to go through
a couple of questions really quick.
And
yeah, one question is, does it work on
FX?
Well, most people that that trade with
the FX, they
will trade the CME FX contracts, the
euro currency. Um you know, it it's very
easy to open a futures account compared
to a forex account. And there's even
micros on forex. But you know, the
difference between a forex market and a
futures market is the data. The data is
centralized in the futures. On forex,
it's not. It comes from many different
sources. And the source, you know, what
you're using to trade against
versus, you know, if you're trying to do
analysis on it, it's not necessarily
giving you all the information.
Sometimes they aggregate the
information.
And sometimes they don't even include
the volume information in there. So, you
know, you
you you want to um
you know, use the
uh what do you call it? Use the the
futures data. Now, the surge, you know,
questions about the surge, we are
recoding it because there's
there's um
an issue with it in the license server.
It's asking people for, you know, it's
not reading it because it's not reading
the license server. We're hopefully
going to get that up the new version out
um hopefully soon, this weekend.
Um the surge is a free indicator on the
website.
But I just showed you how to see it on
the order flow chart, so, you know, you
you can see it. It's nice to have it,
but um you know, again, it it's nothing
um super fancy about it.
But again, you know, we are updating
what was on the website cuz there was a
new thing on the NinjaTrader 8 upgrade
that caused a little bit caused it not
to give any signals for some reason.
NinjaTrader, again, the indicator the
order flows trader software runs on
NinjaTrader.
Okay? I said it'll run on the free
version as well as the paid version. So,
if you have already, you know, your
broker has given you a trading front end
or you use, you know,
um
another platform to trade, you can run
the free version of NinjaTrader, just
put the order flows trader software on
it. You just need a data feed. It will
run on the free version.
Um
Someone asks, how's this different than
NOFT? Well, NOFT is similar. NOFT is a
They changed their names recently, I
think, anyway. Um NOFT is also an order
flow
software. You know, it's a volume
footprint chart.
Um
I don't know much about it. I've never
used it, so I can't really compare.
But it's it's a footprint chart, so it's
uh relatively
similar.
People ask, you know, comparing it to
things like uh ZoneTrader Pro. Again,
you know, ZoneTrader Pro is is another
software. I don't um
I I I don't use anybody else's software.
You know, I know a lot of these
companies have taken my ideas
and put them in their software, but they
don't understand, you know, how to use
it. Like Sierra Charts, right? Sierra
Charts
has a a footprint chart on their
software and
every 6 months or so, you know, people
put on the Sierra Chart message board,
hey, can you add this, you know, and
it's one of my
indicators.
And eventually Sierra Charts gets it,
but, you know,
people don't know how to use it.
Right?
I I teach you how to use
you know, why I have a ratio, how to use
it, the ratio, how to use, you know, how
to find the trap traders, you know,
just because you got an indicator
indicating something, you have to take
it in context with what's happening in
the market, right? If if you just cuz
you got a buy signal, right? The market
just rallied 20 points and you get a buy
signal, do you want to buy it again?
Probably not, right? You've already had
the move. So,
yeah, if you're going to learn
something, learn from the person that
created it rather than somebody that
copied it and put it in their software
for having it in their software's sakes.
Um
let me just go through a few more
questions here.
Can it be used on futures and equities?
Yeah, I I'm a futures trader. I'm from
Chicago. I trade futures, equities. Um
Some equ- you know, equities that have a
lot of volume,
you know, on on thinly traded markets,
you're not going to get enough
information cuz it's thinly traded, so,
you know, order flow revolves around
volume, right? In addition to price and
time. So, if it's not putting in a lot
of volume,
then it's going to be more difficult.
Um people ask, any training? Yeah, I
give a lot of training. I even have I I
didn't put in here, but
I also have a weekly live group training
session that meets Monday nights, 7:00
until about 8:00 Central time. Uh I go
over, you know, interesting things that
I saw in the order flow
um in the last several days, well,
Monday and usually towards the end of
last week.
And again, I've been doing that for the
last couple years.
There's an archive of those videos as
well and, you know, you can go there,
you can ask questions um in there as
well. So,
anyway, I don't want to go on too long.
It's about pushing an hour and a half
already. You know, there's everybody
that's stayed on, you know, thank you
for your time. Um you know, I I realize
that
you know,
to sit through an hour presentation and
then pushing an hour and and a half is
is asking a lot. So,
um you know, any questions, my email is
mike@orderflows.com.
You know, if you're going to send me an
email asking about the the delta surge,
just be patient. Um we're going to get
the new version out, you know, it's just
it's just came to my attention recently
and I've been going back and forth with
with my programmer to get a newer
version um released so that it will will
work
properly. And again, and and that's
that's just something out of my control.
I don't do the programming. You know,
I'm not a programmer um on the trading
side.
So, just be patient on that. And again,
you know, it's very easy to get started.
Again, it's it's the price is affordable
for a lot of people.
Um
and again,
ask yourself, you know, most of you guys
that are interested in trading, you've
been interested in trading for a while
now, right? Ask yourself where you were
a year ago versus where you are right
now. Have you made any progress? What
have you done to make that progress?
Now, think ahead, 1 year from now, where
do you want to be? And think about the
steps you're going to take to get there.
Okay?
You got to get the education, right? If
you can't get the screen time, if you
can't get the actual trading time in,
you got to get the education. There's
just no way around it. Um you know, and
it's just like
you know, studying for an exam, okay?
If you don't know the material, you're
not going to do well on the exam. And if
you don't understand the markets, trying
to trade the markets, you're not going
to do well trading. So,
you know, on that point,
I'll end it. And again, any questions,
just shoot me an email,
mike@orderflows.com. I'll do my best to
get back in a timely manner. And again,
the surge, we should have a newer
version out there. Go to
orderflows.com/oft2.
Have a great weekend, everybody.
Actually, it's Wednesday. Have a great
rest of the week and have a great
weekend.
Bye-bye.